beautiful skies we've got a little color
out there with some clouds around this
morning
but those clouds are sliding away and we
should have a lot more sunshine for your
tuesday than we did on monday
lots of mid 40s around the las vegas
valley a little cooler at
nellis at 41 outside the valley mid 50s
in laughlin 40s mesquite to searchlight
39 up in cedar city kingman down in
northwest arizona's got some mid 40s
caliani's been cold out in the clear
skies this morning at 27 degrees trump
at 43
sandy valley in the mid 40's and some
pretty chilly numbers up north except
for reno where they've been having some
strong westerly winds
temperatures in the abnormally mild 40s
upper 40s this morning normally they
would be in the upper 20s to near
freezing
we're looking for a high of mid 60's
today normal high is 60 degrees that
sunrise by the way at 6 41
and sunset at 509 i don't know if you've
noticed it
but that daylight lingers later and
longer now it's so much it's so nice you
can tell the days are getting longer
all right they're not going to see much
sunlight across the northeast with that
big nor'easter
still slamming the northeast with so
much heavy snow up to
three feet by the time that storm's done
in many areas
all right so our clouds are slipping
away to the south but here up north
is the next system this one's a little
cooler and it will
head our way tomorrow ahead of it those
stronger southwest winds so that's why
we'll be windy tomorrow
with wind advisories from 10 a.m to 7
p.m for
all these areas of blue most of clark
county including las vegas
in that wind advisory for 40 mile an
hour winds tomorrow
then cooler behind it so a couple of
days in the nice mid to upper 60s
then 50s on thursday so it'll cool down
before the weekend
super bowl sunday looks fabulous upper
60s mostly sunny
and we'll hang on to 60s into next week
boy that looks great it's going to feel
like spring